hi and welcome to our session on
building an interactive machine learning
application using both vertex ai and
looker
i'm leah jarrett and i'm a developer
advocate here at google cloud and i'm
also joined by my colleague sarah
robinson
before we get into the details let's
talk about why you might want to build
an interactive data science application
for your team
but we know that business users of all
different types need access to the
results of machine learning models and
we really want to eliminate that
bottleneck so that they don't need to go
through a data team to get access to the
results
we also want to make sure that our data
science application has an easy to use
and simple ui so that people of all
different technical levels are able to
interact with machine learning models
and get the data that they need to do
their jobs
finally we want to provide guidance onto
how business users should interpret the
results of machine learning and also
take action on them so we're making sure
that machine learning is having a real
influence on business decision making
now in this presentation we're going to
talk about how google cloud can help you
build these data science applications
so let's pretend that we are working for
a marketing department of an e-commerce
company
i might decide to create two different
models in vertex ai
first i'm going to create a
classification model to predict whether
or not different users who see an
advertisement are likely to make a
purchase
then we're going to create a time series
forecasting model to predict our
different revenue so we can accurately
measure the lift of those campaigns
now in order to train our vertex ai
models we're going to supply it data
that's coming from our bigquery data
warehouse
this gives us the scale and reliability
that bigquery offers so we're able to
store and transform and prepare our data
for machine learning
finally we're going to use looker to
actually create a custom application
that our business users can interact
with
using looker's extension framework we
can customize the ui exactly for our
needs
and will enable our users to interact
with this ui and have the results of
their interactions sent back to vertex
ai to create new predictions from our
models
now i'm going to pass it off to sarah to
talk more about vertex ai
thanks leah let's start by looking at
what vertex ai is at a high level vertex
ai is our end-to-end managed machine
learning platform on google cloud it's
designed to help you with every step of
your machine learning workflow and it's
designed for people regardless of ml
expertise so whether you have deep
experience building custom models or
you're just getting started with machine
learning we have ways that you can use
vertex ai to add to your machine
learning applications
so here we can see an overview of all
the different products that are included
in vertex ai for each phase of a typical
machine learning workflow we're going to
focus just on a few of these in this
presentation starting with data sets
showing you how to link data in bigquery
to a data set in vertex ai then we'll
look at how to train models in vertex
and get predictions on those models and
throughout this presentation we'll be
focused on models trained on tabular
data to build both a classification and
a forecasting model
let's start by looking at data which is
usually the first part of any machine
learning workflow so in vertex ai you
start by uploading a data set and you do
this by selecting the type of data
you're working with along with the
prediction task that you'll be solving
in this presentation we're going to be
working with tabular data but we also
support a lot of other data types and if
your data doesn't fit into any of these
categories don't worry you can still use
vertex ai to train your own custom
models
next let's look at a decision framework
that i use to help customers figure out
which parts of vertex ai are right for
them
the first question to ask is whether or
not you have your own training data to
use for your model if the answer is no
we have a set of pre-trained apis that
give you access to machine learning
models that have already been trained on
lots and lots of data that you can
access via a rest api
for this presentation we're going to be
focused on the right side of this
flowchart we're assuming that you do
have your own training data that you
want to use to train custom machine
learning models the next question to ask
yourself is whether or not you're going
to be writing the model code and
whatever the answer is to this we have
tools to support you on vertex ai we're
going to be focused on automl for
training but you can also use vertex ai
to train your own custom models built
with any machine learning framework
let's take a closer look at automl for
training
automl is a tool that lets you train
state-of-the-art machine learning models
in less time because you're not required
to write any of that model training code
yourself
all you do is upload your data to vertex
select the columns that you're going to
be using for training along with the
column that has your label or the thing
that your model will be predicting you
press a train button and vertex ai will
iterate over different model
architectures to find the best one
suited for your prediction task when
your model is done training you'll then
get access to detailed model evaluation
metrics along with feature attributions
once you have a trained model there are
a couple options for how to get
predictions on that model the first is
you can deploy your model to an endpoint
in vertex ai
and endpoints live in the same place in
the ui whether you train the model using
automl or your own custom model code you
can also access both types of models via
the vertex ai sdk you can split traffic
between different models and you can
also customize the machine type where
your endpoint is deployed
and if latency is less of a concern and
you have a lot of test examples that you
want to get predictions on you might
want to create a batch prediction job
and we'll show how to do this in the
demo to create a batch prediction you
can do this either in the vertex ai
console or via the vertex ai sdk and
you'll specify where your data is that
you want to get batch predictions on and
then where you want vertex ai to write
the results of those batch predictions
in the demo we'll be creating a batch
prediction job based on data we have in
bigquery
and without further ado let's take a
look at a demo in this demo i'm going to
be showing how to train two different
models using data from bigquery
we'll train a classification model along
with a time series forecasting model and
we'll use automl to train both of those
models when the models are done training
we'll look at some evaluation metrics
and then we'll see how we can create
batch prediction jobs so that we can
then visualize the results of those
model predictions in our looker
dashboard let's go to the demo
we'll train two models in vertex ai
using our retail data first we need to
import our data from bigquery into
vertex
there's a direct integration between
vertex ai and bigquery here we'll create
a data set
this data set will be used to train a
tabular classification model
we want to import data from bigquery so
we'll select here
and this is the bigquery table we want
to use to train our model
it's some data on orders and we'll use
it to predict whether or not a customer
will make an order
we'll enter that bigquery table here
and now we're ready to train a model on
this data
we'll train our model using automl which
means that we don't need to worry about
writing any of the model code our target
column is made order this will tell us
whether or not the customer made a
purchase
here we'll select the columns we want to
use for training
here we'll want auto amount to maximize
the accuracy on our model for the less
common class
we're doing this because the percentage
of
customers who made an order in our data
set is much smaller than those who
didn't
and with that we're ready to start
training
we'll follow the same process to train a
forecasting model to predict sales for
different item categories
here we're using seven days of data to
predict what the category sales will be
seven days in the future
now that we've trained two models let's
see how each one performed starting with
our classification model
here we can see that 77 of the time our
model was able to correctly predict when
a customer would make a purchase
we can also see feature importance
this shows us which features signaled
our model's prediction the most in this
case it looks like the advertisement
category was the most important
indicator of whether or not someone
would make a purchase
with our trained model we can now deploy
it to an endpoint to get online
predictions
we can also request batch predictions by
creating a batch prediction job either
in the ui or programmatically via the
vertex ai
api
the result of our batch prediction job
was written to a bigquery table
for each row we can see the percentage
likelihood that a purchase was made
here it looks like there was a 71 chance
that the customer made a purchase
let's also take a look at how our
forecasting model performed here we can
see some evaluation metrics on our model
when we kicked off our training job we
specified that we'd like test
predictions written to a bigquery table
let's take a look at that table now here
we can see the sales predicted by our
model compared to the actual sales on
that date
now let's see how to create a batch
prediction job looking at one window of
our time series data when we're
formatting our data for prediction we'll
pass it a bigquery table with sales data
for our seven day context window and
then we'll provide the date we want to
generate a prediction on for this model
it's seven days in the future
we'll leave the sales value for that row
blank since that's what we want to
predict we can get predictions on as
many 7-day time series windows as we'd
like here we're just showing one for
demo purposes
when this batch prediction job completes
we'll see the resulting predicted sales
value for the date that we specified
in our looker dashboard we'll be able to
visualize the predictions resulting from
both of these models
thanks sarah so now we understand how to
actually create models in vertex ai and
even hit an endpoint to get new
predictions but how do we extend these
capabilities so that non-technical
business users are able to interact with
vertex ai and analyze the results of
those predictions
this is where looker comes in
so you may already be familiar with
looker's architecture
looker enables you to create a data
model your single source of truth for
all of your different metrics and this
sits directly on top of your data
warehouse so bigquery in our case
for the data science application we
might create a model where we're
actually defining metrics associated
with the prediction results coming from
vertex ai
this will allow our business users to
explore the results and create
visualizations or dashboards and even
operational workflows to take action on
those results
but how do we actually enable them to
interact with that endpoint and create
different inputs that feed into vertex
ai
this is where the extension framework
comes into play
looker's extension framework allows you
to create custom javascript to control
the ui for a custom application hosted
in the looker environment
so the great thing about the looker
extension framework is it handles all
hosting authentication authorization and
gives you access to lookers apis ability
to embed looker components like
dashboards and looks and also we have a
set of open source ui components to
really accelerate your time to value
this diagram really helps put it into
perspective if you want to go and build
a data science application on your own
you have to take care of all of that
stuff outside of looker but with the
extension framework so much of it is
taking care of it for you under the hood
so just to put these two pieces together
first we're going to create a dashboard
using native looker technology we'll
model the prediction results we'll
explore them and create a report that
business users can use
next we'll use the extension framework
to actually customize the ui so it's
purpose built for our models and so that
users can control the inputs that are
fed back into the vertex ai prediction
job
so let's actually see a demo of all of
this in action
i'll jump into my data science
application so we can see how a
marketing person would interact with it
in looker i can navigate to my data
science application from the left side
panel under the applications drop down
or if you're using an earlier version of
looker from the browse drop down
now i can see my custom built
application for the marketing team to
create targeted advertisement campaigns
on the left hand side marketers are able
to control inputs to the model like
selecting users from a certain traffic
source country gender age and previous
purchase history
they can also specify what type of
advertisement they're planning to run
for example here we're predicting if we
fed an advertisement campaign for
accessories through a search channel
on the right hand side we have our
dashboard to actually analyze the
results of the model
so here we can see that when we ran the
model we fed in over 65 000 users that
had an average age of 53 certain average
prior spending habits and we can also
see their geographic location
scrolling down we can start to analyze
the results of the batch predictions
from vertex ai
so here i can see that 2.6
of our user base was expected to make a
purchase
we can also use that information to
calculate our predicted campaign cost if
we just targeted that 2.6 percent
and we can slice our likelihood to make
a purchase so that predicted measure
coming from vertex ai
by other fields in the user information
like how many orders they previously
made what their traffic source was and
what their age group was
next we can look at the results of our
time series forecasting model so to
actually see what our predicted revenue
if we don't do anything is for the next
seven days and see that compared to
prior historical sales
now this dashboard is just like any old
looker dashboard so as a marketer i can
explore from here drill in so i might
want to explore and actually send these
users who we predict to make a purchase
off to an external application to you
know target them for that advertisement
now that we understand how a marketer
would interact with this application
let's start thinking about how we
actually went and built this application
like we said earlier we built this using
looker's extension framework so what we
did was created some lightweight custom
javascript to control the ui that we're
seeing here
on the left hand side i actually used
looker components to create each one of
these inputs
let's see what one of these components
might look like
for example the checkbox group component
is used for first input now i'm a data
person and not a front-end developer and
although i did have to learn a bit of
javascript and react to get everything
working appropriately
most of the application was built
leveraging these components and working
off the extension framework code
templates that are available
now if a marketer wants to change the
inputs to the model for example only
focusing on people in the us and maybe
seeing what would happen if we ran an
advertisement for jeans
i can click run
and i'm going to have to verify my
identity to make sure i have permission
to run the vertex model
and then in the extension framework my
code is actually going to send this
information to vertex to create a batch
prediction job
now before looker actually talks to
vertex it uses the looker api to create
a bigquery table that contains one row
for each person in that audience we
created to predict on
and you can see we're going to have the
gene search campaign which is the fields
that the user entered to actually
see what would happen if we ran a
certain type of advertisement
and then the details of the bigquery
table we can see that it's set to expire
tomorrow so that we aren't storing too
much unnecessary information
and also it's named with this long hash
and this is basically a unique
identifier for the prediction that we're
running
now if we open up our extension code we
can see that after the bigquery table
has been created it's time to make our
vertex prediction call
here we're using lookers extension sdk
to create a post request to google cloud
ai platform and in the input we're going
to specify things like our model id the
location where this needs to run and
also our input data so that bigquery
table we just created and our output
bigquery data set
since batch predictions sometimes take a
few minutes to run we send the user a
message on google chat when the results
are ready with a link to review
here we also include the same hash used
earlier to bring the user back to the
results of the model so that they can
use the dashboard to investigate the
results
the dashboard itself is just a regular
old looker dashboard that's embedded
into our application using looker's
embed sdk so just like previous looker
api calls we made this requires just a
few lines of code and no authentication
needed
we use the embed methods to pass in
values for the filters based on what the
user has entered on the left
you'll also notice that we have a
parameter for our table name this is the
hash that was used to identify the
prediction and it's what's going to be
used to make sure that we're leveraging
the right table that stores the results
of the latest prediction results from
vertex ai
now the great thing about this entire
app is that it was simple to build since
looker and vertex do all the hard parts
like model and front-end development
deployment and authentication
and my marketers can interact with
machine learning all on their own to get
data when they need it
thanks again for joining us today so we
talked about how to build a complete
data science application using vertex ai
and looker sarah walked us through the
vertex ai platform including how to
create train and deploy models and i
showed you how to explore the results of
those models in looker and create your
own custom application using lookers
extension framework
so to get you well on your way to
creating your own data science
application we have listed some
resources like looker and vertex ai
training courses and labs we also
included some other next sessions that
might be relevant to what we talked
about today
so thanks again sarah for joining us and
talking about vertex ai and thank all of
you for joining us today we hope you
enjoyed this session and that you
enjoyed the rest of next 2021
you